what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into sins of the star
sapphire this is actually the first of
three I believe it's three pre ludes to
blacken tonight the next one is rage of
the Red Lanterns and the one after that
is Agent Orange Larfleeze man let me
chase under large leaves are so Opie
it's not even funny to do that guy is do
that guy's ridiculous I mean there's man
but uh yeah like some to the Star
Sapphire is interesting because again
when it comes to these pre lewd stories
it's like these small little tidbits
they kind of get thrown in here and
there and really one of the most
important characters that will really go
into blackest night proper is actually a
guy named Sarah at least I think that's
how you pronounce his name
it's sa a re K regardless of the story
initially picks up with this guy and the
reason why is because we actually join
with this kind of funeral ceremony for
Green Lantern's who have died in battle
and this is actually really really cool
because it shows us what happens
whenever they perish now keep in mind
there are some Green Lantern's that die
and they never recover their corpses and
so as far as unable to tell this
ceremony is never held for corpse that
can't be recovered but for those
lanterns who do die in battle they're
given this very you know honorable thing
in the sense that they're basically kind
of stowed alongside all these other
lanterns who perished in conflict and
their story will be recorded in the Book
of Allah as one of the many instances
when the Green Lantern's were able to
achieve a great goal because remember
for those of you guys who were just now
joining us we're coming out of the
Sinestro Corps war and so of course that
covered the story where Saul Sinestro
basically formed his own Lantern Corps
and led to a massive war with the Green
Lantern's that resulted in the guardians
of the universe rewriting the book of
Allah to allow the Green Lantern's to
kill both members of the Sinestro Corps
as well as anybody who was an enemy of
the Green Lantern's and so again that
was a huge change because it was
something that we had never seen before
now with regards to Sark himself his
introduction comes by way of not really
interrupting this funeral service so
much as partaking of it and basically
being met by the arrival of the
caretaker himself basically the guy
who's sort of in charge of all these
different you know funeral services and
so on and Sarek basically reveals that
he has the telepathic ability to
communicate with the dead and this is
why I say this is so important for
blackest night because as we know with
blackest night it's the resurrection of
the Dead it's one of the reasons why
I've timed a lot of the screen Lantern
stuff so that blackest night will begin
shortly before October and then run all
the
through into Halloween I thought I'd be
kind of cool to do that to do like Green
Lantern blackest night every Sunday all
throughout October I thought it'd be
kind of a cool little thing but the fact
remains here that with Sarek his
presence here is really one of intrigue
and mystery more so than anything else
because remember lanterns don't usually
display a power like this Green Lantern
rings complement the existing powers of
you know whatever being gets a Green
Lantern ring but there haven't really
been any instances when a lantern crops
up and says well I can talk to the dead
because now it becomes a questionable
thing now the other half of this is
what's going on with regards to Kyle
Rayner and Guy Gardner because remember
after the events of Sinestro Corps war
their idea was if they wanted to open a
bar which is actually pretty cool it's a
pretty cool thing just kind of open a
bar on OA but what they end up doing is
talking about the whole idea of like
Mongol and so on and so forth Mongol
being a guy who had basically attained
us several yellow lantern rings but have
been handed over to the black mercy
plant to basically be consumed to quite
literally be physically digested that's
one of the reasons why we covered that
story because going into things like
this they'll touch back on that and I
wanted to be able to very least just
kind of say hey look here's what that
video is it's in the Green Lantern
playlist you're welcome to check it out
what we end up finding out is that
Mongol has basically escaped his
captivity and so what that means is that
now we have a guy who in a lot of ways
is on par with Superman in terms of its
strength and so on that has five
Sinestro Corps rings so it's kind of
crazy in terms of the power that he
possesses but he actually won't play a
very big role here again this is sins of
the star sapphires and so this is
designed to focus more on the Star
Sapphire cores and the Green Lantern
more so than anything else but the cool
thing about this is that it also hinted
the idea that someone is traveling
around and basically killing off all of
the you know the various parents that
belong to members of the of the Green
Lantern Corps and again this is kind of
a big deal because despite the fact that
thousand Estero was defeated and the the
Sinestro Corps was defeated
they weren't destroyed in their entirety
they're all still very much alive and
the Rings are still going out and
pursuing new recruits for the Sinestro
Corps and so with the idea of someone
travelling around and killing the
parents of recruits who are part of the
Green Lantern Corps this presents a very
dangerous situation and the reason for
this is because of the fact that with
them fearing for the lives of their
parents the fact of the Sinestro Corps
is rooted in fear means that they could
easily be pulled away from the Green
Lantern's inducted in the Sinestro Corps
and
all sir the sinestro course numbers but
of course what we end up doing is we
basically pick up with CEREC after the
fact that all these different eyes have
just kind of been dropped down onto
these members of the Green Lantern Corps
when they learn their loved ones are
being killed and Saric basically is able
to go through the the memories so to
speak or the very least speak to the
dead through these eyes and then in turn
gain the identity of the person who's
doing this now again this is where the
plot begins to thicken a little bit and
the reason for that is because of the
fact that once the Green Lantern's are
able to sort out who it is that's
committing these actions the question
now becomes who are these guys going to
be the other half of this is that
because of the fact that so many of
these new recruits have basically lost
their parents because they're not really
forged in the fires of battle and
therefore don't really have the
willpower necessary to overcome
virtually any and all fear and in fact
that they are so susceptible to the
Sinestro Corps they're stripped of their
Green Lantern rings and they're
basically thrown in isolation now again
this is one of the big failings of the
Green Lantern Corps and that's one of
the things that we're going to see at
the you know once we get towards the
conclusion of the story but Before we
jump into that we actually jump in with
a character named ice now normally we
wouldn't really jump into this too much
just because of the fact that she's here
for a little bit she talks to guy
Gardner for a little while the two of
them think about moving in and then
that's it but ice actually gives us a
chance to sort of talk about this
background with Guy Gardner because Skye
Gardner is a character that we haven't
really discussed too much we really
haven't had a reason to outside of
whatever it is he's doing in any
particular story that goes on but Guy
Gardner really has his rise unpopularity
came by way of Justice League
International but the idea of Justice
League International was to basically
take superheroes who couldn't normally
sell their own comics throw them onto a
team have them led by Batman in order to
boost the team's popularity and then
sell comics and it performed exceedingly
well it actually did did a really good
job guy Gardner was for the most part
headstrong he was a guy who just got in
a fight with Batman Batman punched an
out different things like that but he
also started forming relationships and
one of these relationships was with a
girl named ice a girl named Tora Olaf's
daughter I think is what her last name
is but she's very similar in terms of
Iceman in terms you know with regards to
what her abilities are and so on and so
forth the ability to kind of manipulate
ice and snow and so on and so forth the
idea was that this all really came out
of the aftermath of Sinestro Corps Award
with regards to Guy Gardner and ice
herself the two of them had this sort of
on-again off-again relationship but
following Sinestro Corps war and him
travelling back to earth the idea was to
basically rekindle this romance of a
had at some point on the line and
initially the response was well give me
a little bit of time and we'll get
things sorted out which resulted in Guy
Gardner basically retreating back to OA
for about about a month or so in order
to for the two of them to basically get
together and to have a date again
switching back over to you know this
being is going around and killing these
various parents that belong to members
of the Green Lantern Corps this was
really more of a moral assault more so
than a physical assault and the reason
for this is because again historically
speaking when it comes to new recruits
they're very inexperienced they don't
really know how to deal with fear and
pino the Sinestro Corps and so on and so
forth but they're still also very easy
to sway and so the goal of these
creatures at least as it seems on the
surface was to go through kill their
parents make these kids orphans and in
turn embolden them with fear and then
make the members of the Sinestro Corps
we're using the powers of serac what is
it happening here as they not only learn
that this one being has been doing this
but there have been a multitude of
others who are all basically of the same
race who are all identical now of course
this leads to the Green Lantern's
tracking them down killing them and you
know that's really the end that or the
very least filling them into science
cells and that's really the end of that
but the way this begins to lead into the
whole concept of a blackest night comes
by way of the scarred Guardian now as
far as I'm aware this Guardian doesn't
actually have a name they're just
referred to as the scarred Guardian but
the Guardian basically speaks directly
with serac and just says look because of
the fact that you can speak directly to
the dead your new assignment that you
will tell nobody about is to go and find
the corpse of the anti-monitor and find
out what in the world is going on now
again the reason why this matters is
because following the events of Sinestro
Corps war one of the things that the
Guardians have been questioning is why
Sinestro had cropped up the way he did
and the other question was what happened
to the anti-monitor because remember the
anti-monitor is kind of like this
harbinger of death for the multiverse
but when the anti-monitor had basically
been defeated or the very least when the
events of Sinestro Corps war had come to
an end the anti-monitor had been whisked
away and then was effectively turned
into a central power battery or at least
that seemed to be the case as the idea
of the guardians of the universe is to
find out what happened to this guy when
the world happened to the anti-monitor
and where did he go and so what we end
up doing here is we jump into sins of
the Star Sapphire proper and we
basically just kind of pick up with you
know regards to Mongols still going on
his rampage this is say leaving the
planet over black mercies and then just
taking off to the far side of the
universe or whatever but along the way
he comes across
couple and basically destroys their ship
in the process as well as kills one of
them no again this sets the stage for
the idea of the star sapphires and we'll
talk a little bit more about them here
in a second but at the moment one of the
other things that we start focusing on
here is the idea that some green
lanterns out there are engaged in
relationships with one another whether
they're guys and dyes girls and girls
guys and girls whatever the case may be
they're all forming their own
relationships their own you know
connections and so on and so forth and
some of them have gone so far as to
procreate now this was literally some
into green lanterns were just given free
reign on there was really no limit to
what it was a green lanterns could do
with their own relationships they could
form friendships they could form
romantic attachments so on and so forth
but in truth when it came to the green
lanterns this was something that
actually helped to forge willpower this
is something that gave them a reason to
fight because when you're a Green
Lantern and you're a parent if you're
not fighting for anything you're
fighting for your for your kid and so it
always gave you the extra motivation
that you needed to keep on keeping on
but we also end up finding out here is
that in addition to these you know
aliens that have been captured and have
been killing parents of Green Lantern
Corps members we also actually find out
that someone's been going around and
killing the parents of Green Lantern
babies and then taking those babies away
but the introduction of the star
sapphires starts to come by way of this
particular woman whose husband was
basically killed when Mongol attacked
their ship now this woman's name is
actually Miri but she's met with the
star sapphires and this begins to
bolster the star sapphire rank remember
we already talked about the whole
introduction of star sapphires in the
Jeff Jones Green Lantern run when Carol
Ferris was brought in as one of their
ranks what seems to be going on here is
that we're previously the star sapphires
just wanted like a queen and they sent
out this gem that would basically grab
someone and make them the Queen what
they're doing now is they're creating
rings and so the result is that these
rings are now being sent out into the
universe for the purpose of grabbing
people the difference here is that
unlike the Green Lantern's where these
rings were made and then just dispersed
across the cosmos and sent everywhere
instead the star sapphires are far more
conservative about how their rings get
sent out and who it is that's able to
use them so the result is that despite
you know Guy Gardner and ice trying to
have a bit of a relationship together
ultimately he's recalled back to the
guardians of the universe and basically
told her he alongside sodam yada and a
handful of others are going to leave the
Guardians on a mission
to the Star Sapphire home planet of
xamarin now again for those of us who
are new to the whole Geoff Johns Green
Lantern thing if you're just now joining
our videos with regards to the star
sapphires they weren't actually
guardians of the universe
at one point along the line the
difference here is that when the
Guardians basically removed emotion from
themselves some of the female members of
the Guardians disagreed with that and
believed that love was the way by which
life could continue on in any form of
normalcy and so the result was that they
broke off and they travel to the planet
xamarin where they found that the love
between a man and a woman resulted in
the formation of this crystal of sorts
now this crystal was basically used by
the zamarons to form their central power
battery and begin calling themselves as
star sapphires and this is what led and
to Carol Farris the girlfriend of Hal
Jordan being brought in as one of the
star sapphires way back in the 1950s
1960s or not even then maybe was 1970
whatever the case may be when she was
rolled in into the end of the Green
Lantern mythos as well as you know her
return and someone and so forth but what
we also end up finding out here is that
were some of the members of the Sinestro
Corps where these rings have basically
been captured by the zamarons and so on
and so forth some of the female members
have been taken by the star sapphires
and brought in for the purpose of being
reconditioned and that's the nature of
the star sapphires what they basically
do because they believe that love is the
absolute thing that can conquer all the
goal is to basically find individuals
who were devoid of love or who they
believe need love and could also serve
as a member of their of their Lantern
Corps bring them in and then effectively
recondition them and that's what they're
doing with members of the Sinestro Corps
these female members that they
discovered they basically say look
they're filled with hate they're filled
with fear so on and so forth but we can
change them we can fill them with love
and when we do they will be members of
the star sapphires but that's why I say
they don't just send out rings all
willy-nilly to anybody who wants them
they'll just stay on a street corner and
just say you get a ring and you're gonna
ring and you're gonna ring instead there
are a lot more conservative in terms of
who gets them and so again it's really
kind of a cool scenario because what we
end up finding out here is that there's
basically irreconcilable differences the
goal of the guardians of the universe
coming here was to basically say look
you can't just go around creating your
own Lantern Corps because you'll
destabilize the universe love mutates
love changes sure two people fall in
love and then somewhere along the line
they may end up breaking up and because
one of the
so in love they go crazy and kill the
other because they don't want the other
person to be with anybody else just
because something starts out good
doesn't mean that it's going to stay
good and that's the whole basis behind
the guardians of the universe devoting
themselves of emotion is to basically
make the case there just because
something can be a certain way doesn't
mean that it should be a certain way but
this is when we start to get into the
nature of the fact that the guardians of
the universe basically become their own
enemies now switching back over to who
this person is it's going around and
kidnapping these kids it's actually a
character by the name of crib and as far
as I'm aware this is the first
introduction of crib into the whole idea
of the Green Lantern mythos but what
crib has been basically doing is going
around killing off the parents who are
basically Green Lantern's and then
taking their kids with the intention of
whisking these kids away and then
raising them to become Sinestro Corps
members to hate Green Lantern's now this
is not as though cribbed as functioning
in subservience to semester of this is
one of those instances where you see
some existing ruler who's basically
defeated and then petty warlords start
rising up and for the most part that's
pretty standard Wendall Sinestro was
still around before he was captured by
the Green Lantern Corps he was the
absolute ruler he was a guy who was
running the show but with his defeat
there was no one in control and so what
this did is it allowed different members
of the Sinestro Corps to go around and
start practicing their own agendas and
so this is really just kind of an
example of how the Sinestro Corps is
fragmented but they're all still
extremely dangerous and what it is that
makes cribs so dangerous is the fact
that crib can secrete these pheromones
that will basically force other people
to exist under its control and so again
getting back into the Guardians
themselves the reason why they really
become their own enemy and this
particular story is because when they
look at the star sapphires and they look
at what the star sapphires are doing
they look at the actions that they're
committing themselves to in terms of
spreading love all throughout the
universe and so on and so forth because
the Guardians of the Universe
consider love to be a weakness and a
failing as something that will
inevitably lead somebody down the path
of becoming a member of the Sinestro
Corps if they effectively banished all
relationships among Green Lantern's and
so anybody who's a member of the Green
Lantern Corps cannot be in any kind of a
romantic relationship whatsoever they
cannot date they cannot procreate
none of that stuff they have to remain
totally isolated from one another and
the result of that is going to be
exactly what you expect but the fact
remains here with regards to Kyle Rayner
and these various guys fighting against
the character of CREB after realizing
what it is it's
on dis coincides with miry basically
coming along and officially being
inducted into the Star Sapphire Court as
the result is that her job is to
effectively go out find people who are
trying to destroy love anywhere in the
universe and then bring them back to the
planet of Zam rod that's the nature of
the star sapphires it's almost like the
Sinestro Corps when a person is so
strong that all they do is instill fear
or something like that they rule with an
iron fist or they make other people
terrified of them they're effectively a
bully a Sinestro Corps ring will
suddenly pop up and say such and such
you have the ability to instill great
fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps that kind
of a thing the zamarons will basically
pop up with a ring that says you know
you have the ability to create great
love or whatever in the world that it is
and then whisk them off to become a
member of the other star sapphires and
so the result is that where things are
popping off pretty readily back with how
you know kyle rayner and prayer but all
these different guys and so on and so
forth there are two things that happen
here the first is a Carl Reiner's
willpower effectively overrides the
control state Cribb puts on him this is
yet another instance of really detailing
the willpower of Kyle Rayner there's a
reason why he was the host of the
willpower entity when he was I on
because he is in a lot of ways the
living embodiment of will now of course
this is a role that will be passed on to
Hal Jordan and the new 52 going into DC
rebirth but at this moment right now in
terms of how he acts in terms of his
total lack of fear in terms of his
ability to maintain his mental faculties
in almost any situation Kyle Rayner is
effectively the embodiment of willpower
and this coincides with the arrival of
Miri as a member of the star sapphires
and so again because Star Sapphire Rings
are best utilized against red lantern
rings which they can basically shut down
if they make a member of the Red
Lanterns for your love and because they
cannot be affected by the orange Lantern
ring of avarice while they're not the
most effective against a Sinestro Corps
rings they're not like super effective
against them the actions of Miri here
actually helps to sort of conquer Cribb
just because of the fact that Mary's
presence is indicative of the fact that
crib is basically trying to separate a
mother from its baby and so the result
is that with the help of Miri as a star
sapphire the Green Lantern's are
basically able to defeat crib and the
result is that the baby is born pretty
healthy or as healthy as a baby can be
under this particular circumstance but
following this what Miri also does is
she actually invokes the desires
both kyle rayner as well as cirrhotic
not two of course the daughter of
Sinestro she basically says look the two
of you all need love love is a necessity
love is something that has to exist and
this again is kind of a funny situation
because what this does is it highlights
the nature of Green Lanterns Green
Lantern's are not like the guardians of
the universe the guardians of the
universe purge themselves of all
emotions but the Green Lantern's have
not purged themselves of emotion they
feel anger they feel love they feel hate
they feel fear which is why so many
Green Lantern's are always in danger of
falling to the Sinestro Corps falling to
the Red Lanterns because of the fact
that they feel emotion as the result is
that mirrors the o'meara simply says if
you do not believe that love is
necessary then simply look into the gem
of the star sapphire I don't know what
it'll show you and neither of you know
where it'll show the other all you know
is what you see and we're not told
explicitly what it is the kyle rayner or
sir onyx see but the idea is that given
what we and what ends up happening later
on with the two of them kind of bumping
uglies that they end up getting together
more or less they just kind of see each
other in love but the biggest action of
this the biggest result of this
particular circumstance the fall out of
the guardians of the universe
effectively banishing love between the
Green Lantern's is that there are
countless Green Lantern truly countless
but there are hundreds if not thousands
of Green Lantern's that abandon their
post they basically say if I'm not
allowed to be in a relationship with a
person that I love so long as I'm a
Green Lantern then I'm not going to be a
Green Lantern and again this makes sense
because remember not everybody who was
inducted into the Green Lantern Corps
did it willingly not only that a lot of
people came from their own lives they
basically have their own wives their own
husbands they have their own families
they undertook that role because they
felt a responsibility to keep the
universe protected and the power of the
Green Lantern would ensure that their
families protected more so than they
could just by using whatever natural
talents they had but their loyalty is to
their friends and family not to the
Green Lantern's and so what ends up
happening here is it again because the
fact that they're faced with this choice
to either continue their relationships
or abandon the Green Lantern Corps they
abandon the Green Lantern Corps and this
reduces their number by a pretty good
margin in a pretty short amount of time
now those numbers will bolster and those
numbers will go back up but in the
interim blackest night is coming and so
the result is that the war of light it's
going to be something to behold it's
going to be absolutely bonkers by the
time it's all said and done but at this
point
we start to get out of the realm of the
stories that are interesting but not the
greatest and we start to get into the
stories that are really good like rage
of the Red Lanterns and like Agent
Orange oh man dude I love Larfleeze but
let me know down in the in the comments
section because I'm kind of curious let
me know in the comments section which
Lantern Corps is your favorite because
I'm kind of curious I imagine people I'm
adding a lot here we're going to say red
I'm as well people are going to be like
yeah man those red lanterns man they're
just pissed off all the time I have no
idea but anyway guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here too comments explain it
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob for the guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
[Music]